uh well i got bad news my friends the
civility is is
is is coming undone keep going this is a
horrifying
and tragic story oh i'm terrible i bring
you now to san francisco to the vile
streets
where a youtuber was detained for
defecating in nancy pelosi's driveway
during live stream
what has become of our great nation on
live stream
what platform was he saying how did they
get away from so apparently this guy's
homeless
oh and he was making a point about
pelosi and he said that was for
president trump and i'm just like
the video poopalosi was watched watched
19 000 times before it was removed from
youtube
he called the incident a peaceful
protest yeah he should have called it a
biohazard
so i i i i said at this guy on twitter
because i'm like
and you know okay maybe i should chill a
little bit but come on man
you know come on come on man come on man
poop on people's stuff yeah i mean it's
her driveway that's fair no i just don't
like the idea of protesters going to
people's houses and making a thing of it
because the left is
the left has been doing that and you're
you're you're just
if if we're going to play this game
where the left and the right are like
all right we'll one-up each other
dude it's why the kings built castles in
the first place because the people would
go to their house so they're like we
need walls
it's just coming full circle you mean
like small castles
well they first they'd be able to keep
like build a wall and then they build a
bastion around their keep which is like
a wall around their walled
house so that you really got to keep the
peasants out man i know
all the peasants disgruntled peasants
will go to the leader's house and
apparently poop on it
so that's all right okay okay well maybe
we've got to get castles in the sky
we got to figure out what happens we got
to figure out what's going on at the
core of this scandal
yeah i want to know poop gate pelosi
poop gate i don't know
uh so they say the live stream shows a
man known as mando walk to the house
to the house speaker's home stand in the
driveway survey his surroundings
and then squatted and defecated in front
of the home
they say uh mando said that his comment
about trump was satire
and he supports the president's
accomplishment but fears america is
becoming one big burned down city
in a subsequent video mando said he was
detained by officers of the bay area
rapid transit police it was scary man
they asked me about kamala harris and
how i joked on the stream
that if she lived in san francisco i'd s
on her house
they weren't effing playing it was scary
i thought my life was over in that
moment he told his viewers
they kept asking me are you this are you
that are you antifa
and the capitol police were definitely
watching my channel because i could hear
them on radio like
tell him to turn off the stream what do
you what is this cat doing who wants to
play
a bart police spokesman a spokesperson
told the new york post
that law enforcement officials do not
have additional information to release
on his detainment i guess he didn't get
arrested
oh wow because it is legal it's legal to
poop on someone's property
but i guess it's because uh they
decriminalized pooping in general in the
streets
oh this is san francisco yeah and that's
that's pelosi's district man
don't poop on my house if i move to san
francisco
don't move to san francisco i lived
there once dude i went to san francisco
we went down to look at a house i
left my bag in the car we went into the
hotel the apartment came out and
our window-ish car window was shattered
my back is stolen that sounds like that
sounds like that sounds like sf man yeah
so man to apologize to pelosi in a now
deleted tweet writing that he wasn't
proud of his actions yeah and he harbors
no ill will toward the democratic
politician
saying i know you may not ever see this
but i want you to know i meant
no foul harm yesterday when i did what i
did
i'm not proud of it at all and i just
would like for you to know that
i have no ill will against you or anyone
in elected officials position
i think he's just saying that because he
got detained and got freaked out when
they were like
why are you oh he's like i just had to
go
don't i didn't i didn't mean i guess i
guess he said he actually is homeless
okay and so what are you gonna do it
doesn't seem malicious
was it would you consider this malicious
um
no mischievous definitely yeah that's a
better way to put it i guess so but yeah
it doesn't seem malicious
he didn't seem angry i mean i'm just
reading context i mean
i think the internet creates these
things and we got to be careful about it
because
the only reason he did is because he
knew he could film it and send it out
now he's going to get and now everyone's
talking about
gofundme right go fund me yeah
well we got another another story in the
in the uh pelosi saga
oh boy i can't believe this one this one
is is hilarious
cnbc's jim cramer calls pelosi crazy
nancy to her face
then blames donald trump the dude
freudian slipped i think he did it on
purpose you think he did it
i don't think so that's what i read so
he's talking to her
and he's like how are we gonna get what
okay here we did they have the quote
uh they don't have the actual quote they
just said sorry that was the president
where's the actual quote come on come on
come on
uh nah he didn't that's that's stupid
you need the actual quote to understand
the context they say
cnbc's jim kramer called house speaker
nancy pelosi crazy nancy to her face
tuesday morning
utilizing the nickname president trump
has given her sorry that was the
president
kramer immediately said after the slip i
have such reverence for the office i
would never use that term
pelosi pelosi laughed and said but you
just did
but you just did and then called trump
the master of projection
so then jim cramer won like a tweet
spree it disgusts me that she is called
crazy nancy
she has spent her whole life in public
service my critics didn't listen to why
i mentioned it
because it is horrifying nah he slipped
up does he like
donald trump i can't tell i i don't know
i mean
he did say before kovid the best numbers
of our lives
in terms of the economy he's kind of
non-partisan maybe
i don't know no he's calling what trump
says horrifying he says did anyone
bother to listen to the whole interview
it was about how horrendous it is the
president calls speaker pelosi crazy
nancy
it is so unfortunate and ill-advised the
people criticizing me must have not have
realized the point
never should she be called that nah he
slipped up he definitely
i thought he did it and then he was like
oh that was donald trump so you know
what i mean you know
well we would never oh cool we can play
it i can i can try to make it play
so uh let's see let's see if we can make
this play and you can actually hear what
he said
between you and i think secretary
mnuchin i mean what deal can we have a
crazy nancy i'm sorry that was the
president
i i have such reverence for the office i
would never
use that term but it is like you just
didn't
but you just did you know he slipped up
he's he's he's he's slipped up i'm gonna
disagree with you there you go
initiative
yeah why because making a point about
how gross it is
oh you think he made himself look like a
bad guy to show like that's a bad thing
oh oh oh i thought you meant he was
intentionally calling her crazy no i
think no i think he's making a point
about how
what do you think i don't really know
it's hard to tell because
that doesn't seem like something that
would just slip out honestly
does it yeah it does really i think so
i it sounds to me like he slipped up
like behind the scenes he's like ah
crazy nancy she's always doing this
and then when he's talking to her he's
like how can we come to a deal you know
crazy nancy and then whoa whoa whoa i i
didn't mean it
like you saw you immediately was like i
didn't mean it i didn't you know it was
that's the president so maybe so what
you're saying is that this is basically
just like locker room talk
that kind of worked its way out into the
conversation yeah so i think that
everyone's entitled to a little bit of
locker room talk you should be able to
say whatever you want to say around just
your friends or you know whoever hangs
out with you at home
i i just think crazy nancy is incorrect
why so like she's not crazy she's not
crazy she's crazy she's not crazy
no she's uh crooked yeah
disl disconnected she's too wealthy
do you see that video where she's like
showing the ice cream off and she's like
i got all this expensive ice cream yeah
and she's laughing i gotta get my hair
done and everyone's like seeing that
unemployed oh yeah the mask
thing the mask thing ladies and
gentlemen i have some art for you oh
yeah we got more art i got art for you
this is a better example of what nancy
pelosi is once again
from george alexapolis for those that
are just listening i will describe it to
you the first panel is nancy yelling
and she's sparkling it was a setup i was
wearing my mask
then the next panel it gets dark and
just the same the same mask
and then the next panel is her looking
down and grabbing her face and then she
rips her face off
i'm wearing now and her face is the
alien from the movie they live
yeah cloudy rottie piper
viper he says uh i'm here to kick ass
and chew bubble gum
and i'm all out of bubble gums it's the
longest fight scene from any movie
is it really i don't know it it goes off
like 20 minutes though okay just
punching each other in the face
they live is about uh rowdy roddy piper
well he was like wwf right yeah
big time he's one of the hottest wwf
wrestlers against hulk hogan
so he finds these sunglasses and when he
puts them on he can see
through the the illusion it's a cool
movie and there's all these people
around who look like
this art depiction of nancy pelosi's
face they're like they have no lips and
their teeth are showing their aliens or
whatever yeah
and when he takes them off they go back
to normal and then he puts them back on
he looks like a billboard
and it says obey he takes them off and
it's like you know enjoy sweet sweet
cola and he's like whoa
and he looks at money and the money says
this is your god it was prolific for
itself it was amazing
it got a lot of traction in about 2012
when the truther movement really struck
the internet
and they love that movie they live
interesting so anyway this art is
uh it's based on nancy pelosi where she
went to the the uh
hair salon and she wasn't wearing a mask
and she was getting her hair done in the
salon and then she blamed the salon
saying i was set up
i was i was wearing my mask and then she
rips her face off
yeah it's brilliant i love it so yeah
she's disconnected man that's my that's
my take on it she's just doesn't know
what she's like you gotta shake [ __ ] you
gotta not go out and do that
show show more of his art look at this
that so that's is i'll uh yeah there's
there's nancy right there oh
so this is from this is this is a book
we got sent from george and it's really
really amazing stuff he's g
prime85 on twitter and the cover is just
nancy pelosi
shredding the trump trump's speech it's
it's look at her face
oh my god it's amazing art she's so good
i don't know what that is just victim
comics oh it's a trump supporter on the
back
so anyway when she ripped up the speech
when she's eating the ice cream ivory
tower nancy but it's not alliterative
you know
crazy nancy isn't either how do you do
what's it what's an n-word yeah
negative's too long
negligent too long yeah it's a long word
the idea is that she's disconnected is
good but doesn't get to the core
of what she is in my opinion princess
pelosi
that's pretty good yeah i think that's
okay yeah yeah
she's got her ice cream she's got her
hair dude and let them eat cake
it makes her sound young which she wants
so maybe it's not the right
then the old lady polo the wicked nancy
of the west
i like that too i like the wicked nancy
because she is she is in the way yeah
over on the west coast
so i think princess pelosi is pretty
good i like that princess pelosi
i mean but princess is usually like a
positive connotation no it's very
young beautiful so well among girls it's
very negative if you're a princess
you're
high maintenance you know you get your
hair done all the time you got the long
nails you got
you know you got the uggs yeah and she i
don't think that's
she's not like that really but the fact
that she went and had to get her hair
done
in the middle of this when other people
aren't supposed to yeah it's really like
she doesn't have control or something
but they've all they've all it's not
just her
lori lightfoot did it and didn't
gretchen whitmer do it i'm sure she did
it's been it's been a whole bunch of
different politics but no i have to get
my hair done
i'm in the public eye and it's not dudes
is it no i don't think so because the
guys wake up with their hair all greasy
and they're like
just splash it with water and comb it to
the side and i'm good to go
or they put on a beanie because they
don't have hair that works too
but these these female politicians we've
seen several of them say
i have to be the public face so i'm
going to go to the salon even though no
one is allowed to
yeah like chris cuomo's the male version
uh
going out telling people he's not going
out but going out yes well he's not a
politician though
no he's not his brother is do you see
tucker carlson at central park fishing
super old video that guy walked up to
him joey boots man he held it together
that was something
yeah sucker's cool dude yeah i like him
uh that's sad you know joe
joey was a cool dude uh he died a little
while ago oh
and i knew him and uh he's the famous
guy who uh i don't know if he's the guy
who made up the baba bowie thing but he
would run up to news cameras and yell
baba boo
and so he would walk around new york
filming people and he didn't realize he
was talking to tucker i guess back then
that's a really really old video oh
i don't think tucker was uh was that
famous back then okay like he was
like he he was you know good stuff he
was the bow tie guy
i was like no no no no no that was so
long ago dude
so long ago but yeah if you didn't see
it this video surfaced of uh
joey boots he was uh he was a friend of
the howard stern show and he like sees
tucker carlson fishing
in central park and he's like what are
you doing that guy's like fishing and
he's like
you can fish here and he's like yeah and
tucker is just like you're filming me
and he goes yeah he goes
why he's like cause i'm allowed to he
goes i'm not questioning your right to
do it i'm just wondering why you are and
then after a couple seconds
tucker just explains to him fly fishing
he's like let me show you and he like
shows his tray he's baited
that was really nice yeah and it was
like a regular conversation yeah and
it's kind of it's kind of it's cool it's
cool and it's kind of sad because joey
was a cool dude he's kind of a
kind of a troublemaker a character yeah
his character so that's not the male
version of nancy pelosi
it has nothing to do with no way
nothing's going on right now or opposite
yeah yeah
what what were you thinking upset oh
just how are people obsessed with their
own personal
well-being in the time where they're
asking everyone to take a sacrifice
yeah so i don't know maybe it's i don't
want to blame it on females but looking
good for the camera
is you know women are doing your hair
done and their makeup done it's like
i don't really like that stuff anyway
personally unless unless i'm missing
something i'm not seeing guys do it
and it's probably because the guys wake
up and they wash their hair and they
comb it and they walk out
but you know women like it it's why uh
hair services for men can be cheaper
depending i mean you have
you have long flowing locks ian so your
hairstyle thank you for noticing you
probably have expensive hair treatment
for
your hair i use a baby shampoo do you
really
yeah that's awesome if you if you
if you went to a salon that you have a
lot of hair to work with they're going
to charge you a lot more so guys tend to
have short hair they're kind of like
whatever you know
yeah salons as a business are kind of uh
you know interesting phenomenon so the
reason that it
it costs more this is actually for the
exact same reason that pink tax
is that's it feminism patriarchy yes
it's the pink tax that's all there is to
it no women's hair is layered
it's longer it's women are more picky it
takes longer for them to do it
and the same thing goes with women's
clothes when you um dry clean it there's
a lot more tucks and pleats and it's
more tailored and it's more fitted and
it requires a lot more
like structure would it be cruel and
unusual punishment
if we said that any politician who
violates the the coveted lockdown to get
their haircut had to get their heads
shaved
oh and then like lori lightfoot gretchen
whitmer and pelosi got their heads
shaved
i think the answer is yes that doesn't
seem kind of unusual
if nothing else cruel and but there have
been instances of unusual punishment
yeah like i remember seeing stories
where like a judge sentenced some dude
to like hold a sign by the freeway
who what happened i don't know it was
something like he had to hold a sign
saying like he was a shoplifter or
something oh
and the guy was like he's like it's like
either that or you go to jail and he's
like i'll take the sign
and so it's kind of unusual but wouldn't
like i don't know what the exact story
was but wouldn't you rather hold a sign
by a freeway than go to jail oh because
it wasn't cruel so it has to be cruel
and unusual it's not true
i think for women that shaving your head
like that would be cruel and unusual
because it's gonna take a long time to
grow back yeah well they really care
about it what if what if you had to
dress up like a clown
like oh you want to look good for the
camera well now there you go
you have mandatory clown duty and you
have to dress up like a clown
i used to do this as a job you actually
did your eclipse woody from toy story
darth vader clown and then i'd make
balloon animals for kids oh how funny
i like that thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you